[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Janina gavankar and I play
commander iDEN versio leader of the
Inferno squad in Star Wars Battlefront 2
I'm also an advocate for in-depth cinema
caliber story in games that tweet from
John boyega was like the tweet heard
around the world it spoke for all of us
when between Austin an untold story a
story that delivers new perspectives and
enables us to play as some of our
favorite Star Wars characters while also
introducing new ones and just like rogue
one tells an essential Star Wars story
ahead of a new hope Star Wars
Battlefront 2 will tell a new Star Wars
story that helps bridge the gap between
Return of the Jedi and the force awakens
it's good but EA didn't just stop there
we loved the previous battlefront of
2015 but we wanted more star wars
battlefront 2 is much bigger than the
previous title with more than three
times the content of the first game
now I'm all about that couch co-op and
they're bringing it back with the return
of skirmish so I'm going to be cuddling
up with someone playing me some
battlefront - in multiplayer there are
more heroes more vehicles more planets
I've been to some of them more space
battles and Starfighter assault and
deeper progression and customization as
well as content from across all eras but
as we know Star Wars is not just some
checklist of great features
how does battlefront to play the team at
Dyson Stockholm has some of the most
talented multiplayer designers in the
world and they've been working with the
EA game changes to make sure star wars
battlefront 2 has the multiplayer we're
all looking for these game changers they
basically get like tapped on the
shoulder because the best battlefront
players in the world and then they get
secretly flown out to Stockholm as long
as they provide valuable feedback they
get an early look at the game sounds
like an awesome program and if I didn't
suck at multiplayer maybe I get an
invite that's true
so let's hear more from them about their
time at dice after the release of Star
Wars Battlefront 1 the community thought
there should have been more and the good
news is this the developers had been
listening
I'm really excited to let the
game-changers get their hands on the
game this is going to stay right sorry
the clean UI look is gonna stay there's
still time to change something if it's
not working oh my god
my first impression with the game is
upgraded all three eras are gonna be in
the game got a whole bunch of new
features one of the biggest ones that a
lot of fans are excited about is the
class system they split the characters
up into different classes they have
different weapons special abilities that
you can customize it affects your health
it affects how you are gonna support
your team there's gonna be more content
you're gonna have to get used to a lot
of new different techniques on how to
play the gunplay and the weapons have
completely been redone compared to the
first battlefront now there is a length
and skill gap in it feels a lot better
and GOG this gun feels kind of more real
less Floyd which is your favorite arrow
so far oh we're introducing a system
called battle points which will allow
you to become not only heroes but other
things on the battlefield as you're
helping your team play the objective you
gain these points there's such a
plethora of things to spend it on
vehicles or even coming in as a hero and
the coolest thing I think is a level
customization not just from a weapons
standpoint but the actual characters own
abilities
collaborating with the game-changers is
always a really great working
environment when you're trying to figure
things out I mean to know that you're
giving give feedback to make it a better
experience for everybody
it's like putting your footprint out
there and saying look I'm part of this
you're on a position yeah ready ready so
I'm going to participate in making the
trailer it's a whole different level of
fantasy 3 2 and now on behalf of the EA
game-changers and dice this is the world
premiere of Star Wars Battlefront 2
multiplayer gameplay
[Applause]
you
[Music]
sector is clear nothing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait Star Destroyer but we need to
clear that escort it's giving everything
we got
your next assignments they are usual
Yoda Darth Maul wookies kylo Ren vs. ray
I watched that thing like 20 times
backstage with my mom before this even
started my mom's here yes it's a big day
for me I'm sorry so okay so we have even
more exciting things for you in just a
moment you two personality iJustine
shoutcaster alex golden boy mendes and
dice developer paul Koechlin will
showcase a salt on feed the world
premiere of Star Wars Battlefront two's
multiplayer yep we've got 39 game
changers ready to go head-to-head in a
twenty versus twenty match babylon feed
and i'm going to take the 40th slot
close it okay but you're not gonna want
to miss this because like maybe you've
seen some teasers but this is the real
thing okay all the bells and whistles
all the newness but before we take you
there another big Star Wars Battlefront
fan has some exciting news hi guys it's
John boyega here thought I wasn't gonna
turn up yes I was but I'm sorry I can't
be there with you because I'm doing a
play in London but I do have some great
news obviously you know I'm a massive
fan of Star Wars Battlefront 1 and now
we're going into the next chapter with
Star Wars Battlefront
2 and I'm very very excited to share
this news with you we've seen Yoda we've
seen Luke we've seen all the other
characters but where's Finn Finn will
definitely be a part of Star Wars
Battlefront 2 alongside with Captain
phasma as part of the first season of
free content and there's more on top of
that we also get to play on the new
planet crate that you saw at on the last
Jedi teaser trailer in April so this is
going to be an exciting time I'm gonna
be playing if you see Finn running
around whooping some ass it's me so I'm
getting ready getting set for you guys
to play with me on Star Wars Battlefront
2 and I'm excited let's play
okay but did you listen Quinn and phasma
are headed to Star Wars Battlefront to
this holiday and it will be free yes
the team at dice heard our feedback loud
and clear on the previous battlefront
and are committed to keeping this
community together with themed seasons
of content post launch for all players
at no additional charge
so the first season inspired by Star
Wars the last Jedi is only the beginning
of the additional content coming to this
game all post-launch heroes maps weapons
and vehicles will be free for everyone
who owns Star Wars Battlefront 2 yes and
yesterday EA announced that players who
pre-order will get early access to
multiplayer beta and Yoda's epic
lightsaber mastery star card so let us
recap new essential Star Wars story
multiplayer across all three Star Wars
eras space battles split-screen co-op
and free content that will keep us
playing together for years to come
yes right yes yes I am so honored to be
a tiny little part of this team making
this amazing game I can't believe they
let me do this today and I can't wait to
play the game in its entirety in
November and I get to start right now so
I'm gonna go pick up my controller and
I'm going to throw it over to iJustine
and Golden Boy and Paul to take us to
assault on Theed the world premiere of
Star Wars Battlefront two's multiplayer
thanks so much hey guys welcome to the
world premiere of Star Wars Battlefront
2's multiplayer gameplay assault on the